Michael Jordan had a celebrity softball
game in the Bahamas I was 10 years old
Jordan's sneaking out of the back I
asked him for autograph he looks at me
he turns around and says one day make me
want your autographed kid and just walks
off like nothing else like he didn't
even budge one day make me want your
autograph for my first got in
professional baseball I told my agent
that that was like one of the main
things that we work to is to get this
Jordan deal I already customized some
painted Jordans waiting on these to get
to the big leagues after the season we
started talking to Jordan because they
saw it and they liked it and they told
me like hey sign with like a one-year
deal somewhere else then we're gonna try
and see what we could do so then I ended
up signing a two-year deal with Nike but
then that Jordan deal came through and
that was like yeah you can't compare to
that so like I have to like go and tell
him that because now that I'm a Jordan
athlete he has my autograph